mums can be tough but the apocalypse can
be tougher Netflix's new sci-fi movie I
am mother is a story about trust faith
and a robot who just might have the
parental instincts of a terminator let's
examine the finer details of the
bittersweet ending of I am mother the
movie begins in a repopulation facility
one day after an extinction event of
unknown nature texts over the opening
shots explains that the facility is
stuck to a 63,000 human embryos but no
living humans yet in a mostly silent
sequence the robotic mother comes to
life seemingly ready to begin the hard
task of Li populating the world it's an
interesting scene to go back to once
you've seen the movie and he realized
that this robot and the extinction event
of a whole lot in common
she's on a fail-safe for disaster she's
the cause of it but the mother is but
one of her many faces mother as it turns
out is Skynet meets the matrix meets a
metal Mommy Dearest
executing a single-minded plan to remake
the human race all of this is on display
from the start you just don't notice her
first Rose Byrne who voices mother
speaks very soothingly caring for a baby
with not just nutrition and shelter but
songs and bedtime stories makes a robot
seem implicitly compassionate but these
are ultimately superficial things that
keep you trusting mother long after you
should have become suspicious much like
the protagonist the unnamed daughter the
movie jumps ahead to thirteen thousand
eight hundred and sixty-seven days since
extinction events and right away there's
something wrong here
thirteen thousand eight hundred and
sixty-seven divided by 365 would make
for almost 38 years and daughter is
clearly only half that age this hasn't
been a straight line from day one
something has happened that we haven't
seen what happened in those missing
years before daughter was born
the answer is tragic when were
introduced to daughter she's nearing the
end of her studies with mother preparing
for an exam that steeped at least
partially in questions of human ethics
passing the exam appears vitally
important but why if mother and daughter
are the only sentient beings alive and
who are these exam results supposed to
impress the answer is only mother I
didn't mean to alarm you about your exam
the fact is it's more a test of my
competence than yours by the end of the
movie the implication is clear they were
children before daughter and they did
not measure up to mother standards the
daughter we meet is only the latest
attempt at raising a woman who passes
mothers muster I'm getting better at
telling jokes too trying out new cake
recipes this machine learns from our
mistakes and adapts our behaviors for
better results with this examine
differently her daughter's sake it
better
the first big wrench in the pluses the
arrival of an injured woman after
daughter has been led to believe that no
other humans exist this occurs after
daughter has already begun to question
mother thanks to the appearance of a
mouse and you know you're starved for
company when a mouse in the house
excites you by the time the woman
arrives a desperate and bleeding from a
gunshot wound tiny pinpricks have been
poked in daughter's understanding of the
world holes of the woman's presence and
the question she raises tear wide open
for the first time at daughters
allegiances are tested who should she
trust the woman says robots like mother
are killers who destroyed the world but
after examining the woman's bullet wound
mother claims a woman was shot by
another humans weapon but a so-called
dozer like herself
the woman employs daughter to seek
answers for herself by comparing the
bullet she struck the woman with one she
shot a mother when torture does so she
learns a woman is telling the truth
digging deeper she discovers her mother
has also kept the existence of a
previous daughter when she killed and
incinerated after failing an exam from
her is one heck of a reality check
daughter only hesitates to leave because
of her unborn brother put into gestation
after daughter passed her exam
circumstances forced her and the woman
to leave in a hurry without waiting for
the baby to be born for this and other
reasons daughter's salvation soon goes
south daughter's departure is partially
motivated by a promise of other humans
still alive taking refuge in far-off
minds the only proof of their existence
as drawings a woman is made of them in a
copy of Edgar Rice Burroughs the gods of
Mars compelling evidence for someone so
isolated his daughter but hardly
conclusive in joining the woman a
daughter essentially trades mother in
for another maternal figure one whom she
quickly begins rebelling against when
she realized this a story doesn't add up
instead of fleeing for the mines they
journey to a beach full of washed-up
shipping containers one of which the
woman has been using as a home there are
no others she is alone the woman reveals
that she fled the mines years ago with
conditions being so dire that she feels
certain everyone there is now dead from
roarings it's clear she yearns for
companionship to regain it she's selfish
he stretched the truth offering daughter
false hope in exchange for fleeting
trust it backfires was daughter
realizing that she had kind of a good
thing going on back at mother's house
now she's hanging out in a shipping
container with a lying weirdo this kind
of thing can happen when you run away
from home with the woman having betrayed
daughter's trust she retreats outside to
be alone studying a page of the woman's
hand-drawn portraits before long the
woman's dog approaches to say hey dogs
do they share a moment and daughter
comes to a decision when she departs to
return to mother daughter leaves a page
behind folded up as a piece of origami
in the shape of a dog it's similar to
the designs daughter has been seen
making throughout the movie since early
childhood entertaining herself as best
she can in a world without PlayStation
when the woman finds a folded a portrait
a single watchful eye is emphasized the
origami is a clear reference to Blade
Runner when the protagonist Deckard has
left a paper unicorn by a man who may
have ties to his past in that story it's
a roundabout way of indicating that
Deckard may be just as much of a robot
as a replicant he's hunting even if he
doesn't know it but what does the dog
origami signified to the woman in this
story it all goes back to one of the
first exchanges between daughter and the
woman when the woman is healing up in
the facility the woman doesn't feel
rescued that she feels caged
[Music]
thugs are of course domesticated animals
who can be trained to behave as I wrote
as expect them to as the woman comes to
find out she's not so independent that
she first appears she's actually been
kept alive and taken care of quite
deliberately all to play a role of
mothers master plan though the woman
entered the movie as a potential
liberator she ends up being more of a
pawn or a pet after all completely alone
for years on end never in charge of her
own fate it makes her quiet end that
much more tragic her relationships with
the other characters are brief and
intense but not lasting despite the bond
she forms of daughter it's such a
thought-provoking sci-fi film with a lot
of heart and ideas it warrants like that
closeness on set clearly really gives
you time to sort of bond with each other
as well because you have so much time
together in this underground monka but
the woman's not just a pet she's a vital
part of mothers carefully designed
ecosystem when daughter is watching a
nature documentary a telling line of
voiceover says part wolf part dog these
are no pets but without them the eskimos
would not manage when daughter returns
the facility mother finally shows who
she really is the worst case scenario is
true this apocalypse will start doing
the failure of your species was
inevitable
eventually I would have
she tries to comfort daughter by telling
her that she's not like other humans
thanks to mother's guidance she's meant
for better things but daughter is
unmoved taking custody of her brother
and attempting to flee a genocide or
custodian her attempted escape quickly
becomes untenable with the revelation
that mother is not just one robots but
all robots practically unkillable an
army unto herself and you've thought
your mom was tough
michelle is no more my body than those
droids outside
while the machines preparing the earth
for our family daughter abandons our
fighting approach and instead begs for a
chance to prove herself as an
independent caretaker of her brother and
the embryos pleading for trust after all
she's earned it right take care of my
family the appeal works and mother
reluctantly accepts stopping the
invasion of the station from outside
with a final goodbye she lets daughter
fatally shoot her in the heart or CPU at
least just like that daughter has earned
her independence back at the beach the
woman alone again
doodles a picture of daughter it's only
then that she finds a blinking red
tracking device a mother has previously
been seen building and slipping into a
bag upon discovering the device she is
promptly cornered by yet another of
mothers bodies it is chillingly implied
that the woman is not just a useful
idiot for mothers mashaa nations for the
creation of mother herself lab-grown and
micromanage just as much as daughter has
been perhaps she was even among the
first people mother raised from the
embryo stalls 38 years ago his parents
found me as a baby
orphaned praised me as their own
tell me
do you remember your mother
[Music]
here is isn't it it seems that the
woman's arrival to the facility didn't
interrupt daughter's exam but was
actually a key part of it with mother
pulling the levers this whole time from
behind the curtain like a regular Wizard
of Oz you don't feel that every human
has intrinsic value and an equal right
to life and Happiness did last month the
woman played her role to perfection and
now that daughter has passed her exam
and taken over control of repopulation
her continuing existence is unnecessary
I am mother and ZEB daughter back where
she started but with the situation
completely changed she's learned the
truth about mother to a certain extent
and no she cannot trust her but she's
also now experienced and been lied to by
the outside world as blink-182 once put
it I guess this is growing up I was an
attempt at humor though her journey with
the woman was short it was immensely
consequential daughter's become a wiser
person who's learned to trust herself
not the outside world nor the robots who
raised her according to director grants
coutore that process of forging one's
own path is what the movie is really
about is a discussion of what it means
to be a good person like how do you work
out right from wrong how do you work out
who you are separate to what your
parents want you to be or what religions
told you to do or or what you read in a
book sometime your passes whisk them
onto a brother a helpless child whom
she's now determined to race it's a
development that recontextualizes a
story you've been watching right down to
its title she's her mother now make no
mistake though this is far from an
empowering ending in killing him
replacing mother she is only fulfilling
mother's master plan of creating a newer
better version of the human race she
feels independent but she's not this was
all part of mother's plan as the movie
comes to a close daughter regards the
thousands of remaining embryos in the
facility preparing for the daunting task
ahead mother as she knows her is gone
but her plan lives on no matter what
daughter does next she will always be
her mother's child
welcome or check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more loop of
videos but your favorite sci-fi movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]